in order for a Phoenix to be reborn it
first has to die and that's what Dark
Phoenix is essentially about the death
of the x-men franchise of Fox so it may
be gloriously reborn at Marvel Studios
but Wow do we have some questions he has
a spoiler filled look at the biggest and
answered questions in Dark Phoenix at
the beginning of Dark Phoenix the x-men
go on a mission to save to master
North's Menace by a weird space cloud
he's here
no not that weird space cloud
not that one either this is a totally
different space cloud that turns out to
be the Phoenix force and then bad things
happen for two hours but that raises a
big question
didn't Jean already have the Phoenix
force like it just in the last movie
[Music]
x-men apocalypse were set in 1983 a full
nine years before the events of Dark
Phoenix so if she just got the Phoenix
force now what the heck was all that
about at the climax of the film at the
u.s. government decides to crackdown on
mutants rounding up all the x-men in a
campaign to imprison mutants in
concentration camps the x-men break free
in a massive battle but then what yes
somehow after violently destroying a
government train and leveling the
countryside at the cost of numerous US
military lives the x-men are then shown
being totally fine back at school so
what happened and what about all the
other mutants in America by the refugees
of Magneto's Island are they all still
huddling in a mutant camp somewhere
under armed guard out of sight out of
mind apparently remember x-men Days of
Future past in that film the future
turned to hot poop so the cast on the
original x-men trilogy sent to Hugh
Jackman into the prequel trilogy to
create a new timeline with a future was
nice it's sort of worked he saved his
Jean Grey but apparently doomed this
other version because now the prequels
aren't prequels anymore they're a
totally different timeline
it's a timeline where time itself
doesn't seem to work anymore remember
that x-men first class was set way back
in 1963 that means that characters like
Magneto Xavier and mystique should all
be in their 50s or early 60s by the time
Dark Phoenix comes around in 1992 and
yet they didn't seem to have age today
in 30 years even characters like storm
and Cyclops who first appeared in
Apocalypse are still the exact same age
nine years later between the original
x-men films these not actually prequels
whatever Days of Future past was and
Logan does seem to be four different
distinct x-men timelines so congrats the
movies are finally as confusing as the
comics a lot has been written about the
end of Dark Phoenix which reportedly was
totally changed at the last minute
because the original ending was way too
similar to Captain Marvel and the haste
shows because the big battle on the
train that leaves a lot of
questions the main one being what
happened to all the aliens gene have
didn't kill these aliens seem to be
nearly invulnerable shrugging off
bullets a mutant attacks with ease but
like two dozen of them are simply
knocked off the train by optic blasts
from Cyclops or a stronger wind from
storm given how tough they are it seems
likely that most of those aliens
survived a simple fall so what happened
with them are they Solana did they get
back on their missing spaceship and fly
away and as anyone ever go into comments
on the fact that there are aliens on
earth guess we'll never know
speaking of Days of Future past remember
this they told me you control metal hey
you know my mom once knew a guy who
could do that and what about this bit
from Apocalypse I'm here I'm here for my
family too yes the fact that Quicksilver
is secretly Magneto's son is a major
subplot in fact it's the only character
development for Quicksilver and all
three films combined so we have to ask
did they ever have that dang talk and
fortunately we don't know because
Quicksilver disappears from Dark Phoenix
less than halfway through it magneto
meanwhile heads off to Europe to check
out the amateur chess scene and since
this is likely the last time we'll see
these versions of the characters it
seems we'll never find out whether they
ever got closure one thing is certain
though the viewers definitely didn't
after the final credits roll and Dark
Phoenix the first question many x-men
fans have is where was this movie made
we're not being snarky we're just
wondering why with over 55 years of
great x-men stories to choose from Fox
decided to tell the Dark Phoenix story
twice in 7 films especially considering
2006 since the last and is considered
the worst x-men film of them all well it
was until now anyway the fact is there
are so many superhero films and theaters
these days that fans want to need to see
something new why they didn't get
something new here is a question we may
never get an answer to finally the
biggest unanswered question of them all
is simply now what certain eclis there's
still one more x-men film coming from
Fox the horror tinge spin-off New
Mutants which has been delayed and
pushed back on the schedule repeatedly
and the which is currently set to debut
on April 3rd 2020 after that though it's
just
a matter of time before Marvel Studios -
something with the x-men
thanks to that deal with Fox Marvel
Studios films couldn't even mention the
whole concept of mutants so we're not
sure how they'll bring the x-men into
the mix and it's also likely that Marvel
will want to completely recast the
characters meaning fans might be meeting
their third Jean Grey and their third
storm in as many decades it's a big ask
for the audience though Marvel proved
with Tom Holland and spider-man that
they can make it work the ashes are here
we're just waiting to see how the
resurrection goes check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]